by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i get up early i go to
bed early
i get up early i like to putter in the
mornings i like to read the newspaper i
like to have coffee
i was very very bookish i was reading
all the time i'm a weird dropout because
i take college courses all the time
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the
five billionaire habits that you must
copy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one learn how to communicate better with
warren buffett
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person
they increase their value at least 50
percent no i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and
you have to be able to get get both your
ideas and
uh and that's that's relatively easy i
did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now
in terms of my talking later on but it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you habit
number two practice
being fully present with oprah winfrey
everything that is happening to us
is preparing us for whatever is to come
and literally we can see
that this moment has been a moment to
send us all to our rooms
literally for a time out and
whether we wanted to or not it's an
opportunity to reset
to re-organize to rethink where we are
and where we want to be and where we
choose to go
when this pandemic is over and we are
released
back into a new normal everybody keeps
saying we want things to go back to
normal
forget that folks forget that
let go of we want things the way they
used to be we cannot have had this
experience
without being forever changed and those
of us who are
carriers of the light seekers of the
light as you all
are seeking wellness know that you have
to move into wherever this moment is
carrying us so ask yourself what could
you
reset to help yourself be healthier
and well in this moment
in these moments that we're experiencing
no question about it
the pandemic the lockdown the separation
the social distancing
has caused us all to feel some sense of
disorder
i feel it too even though i i literally
am leaning into every spiritual practice
i ever thought i believed in but it
still has caused
disorder and i'm asking myself the same
questions that i'm asking you to ask
yourself
what can the disorder reorder
for you we cannot let this
moment this extraordinary time that
no one in our lifetime has experienced
pass us by and us not get
all that it's here to teach
impact show and evolve us to
so to me the cornerstone of any wellness
is in vision is focus
so i found myself at the beginning of
this pandemic
feeling several things first uh when
lockdown came
i was excited because whoa i thought it
was only going to be like
two weeks and i was treating it like
vacation
and i didn't have to fit into any pants
so i was eating everything
i was like counting the points in my
head but not really tracking them
and then when i realized we're gonna be
longer i thought after i put on
the first seven pounds i said whoa
let's get ourselves refocused and back
on track i was feeling overwhelmed
well but i will tell you that for me
being the practice of of
being fully present has saved me and one
of the reasons i was feeling overwhelmed
and eating my way through the first two
weeks is because
i had just come off of that tour and i
saw many of you i see some faces that i
saw
on the tour hey lisa job i see you there
um
i um uh and and i realized
you know as more and more information
was coming forward that wow
i after every show y'all shook
had 400 500 people
waiting in line to take pictures and
shaking hands so i shook hands
i hugged people people kissed me i
kissed them we cried we danced we did
everything and then i thought 14
for the first 14 days after the tour
finished
every day i was waiting to like know
whether or not
i was going to be a victim of covet 19.
i am in the at risk risk category i am
66
never before have i been reminded of
that number because at first when
the news started coming out about uh it
affecting elderly people i was like oh
so sad the elderly people then i
realized they were talking about people
over 60 oh they're talking about me
oh oh i didn't realize i was elderly
okay thank you so much and as i've
shared with so many of you i had
pneumonia last year so
i'm really in that category of at risk
so i was worried and
if you're watching the news every day as
i know we all have been
needed it for information i have now
stopped and limited that for myself if
you're watching the news every day
you can get overwhelmed with the stories
and i was reading
every terrible horrible story of what it
does to your body and how it shuts down
your lungs and then it makes your heart
race and then your kidneys fail and
all of that okay do i have a witness
over there i see you linda and so i had
to stop i had to stop doing that
i had to stop doing that and every time
i would i would get overwhelmed i would
do this i would just literally
go to my breath and remind myself that
breath
is the presence of life it reminds you
that the breath
is literally the source of life for you
come back to focus and i would say in
this moment
i am well in this moment i'm okay
i am not in the hospital i am not on a
respirator i am not
that story in this moment i am breathing
i am well i'm okay coming back to the
moment coming back to the moment
reminding myself in this moment i am
well
so i believe that the first step toward
focus is to start
exactly where you are also if you want
to have
unstoppable confidence self love and
learn from billionaires check out my 254
series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below it's important to associate with
people that are
better than yourself how to be myself
completely on television
the number one thing that has made us
successful by far
is obsessive compulsive focus on the
customer
habit number three get enough sleep with
jeff bezos
you uh sit around with your team and so
forth but you don't like meetings before
10 a.m no you like to get eight hours of
sleep and you don't like
um power points explain all that why is
that okay
many so i i like to putter in the
morning i get up early i go to bed early
i get up early i like to putter in the
mornings i like to read the newspaper i
like to have coffee i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have
my kind of puttering time is very
important to me
and so that's why i set my first meeting
for 10 o'clock
i like to do my high iq meetings before
lunch
like anything that's going to be really
mentally challenging that's a 10 o'clock
meeting
and because by 5 p.m i'm like i can't
think about that today
let's try this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and
and so then on sleep i get eight hours
of sleep i prioritize it unless i'm
traveling in different time zones
sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and
and for me i need adults to sleep i
think better
i have more energy my mood is better all
these things
and think about it as a senior executive
what do you really get
paid to do as a senior executive you get
paid to make a small
number of high quality decisions
your your job is not to make thousands
of decisions every day
so let's say that i slept six hours a
day or let's go really crazy and say i
slept four hours a day
so now i just got four so-called
productive hours back
so if i was going to you know
have say 12 hours of productive time
during
any waking day now all of a sudden i
have 12 plus 4 i have
16 productive hours so i have 33
percent more time to make decisions so
if i was going to make
you know 100 decisions now i can make
133 decisions
if i did that arithmetic wrong i'm sorry
and and so you make 133 decisions
is that really worth it if the quality
of the decisions might be lower because
you're tired or grouchy or
any number of things now it's different
if it's a startup company i mean you
know you're really
you know when amazon was 100 people
that's a different story but
but amazon's not a startup company and
all of our senior executives
operate the same way i do they work in
the future they live in the future
none of the people who report to me
should really be focused on the current
quarter
um i always tell people sometimes i get
you know we'll have a good
um quarterly conference call or
something and
and wall street will like our quarterly
results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working
on a quarter that's going to reveal
itself in 2021 sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know
two or three years in advance and if you
are
and then why do i need to make 100
decisions today if i make like
three good decisions a day that's enough
habit number four
read more with elon musk i certainly was
quite um i was very very bookish i was
reading all the time so i was either
reading
working on my computer reading comics
playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing and um i understand
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
that wonderful book by douglas adams
that was a that was a key book for you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination
um yeah so uh i guess when i was
in uh around 12 or 13 i had company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um on trying to figure out the meaning
of life and
well like what does it all mean because
uh it
starts seeming quite meaningless and
then um
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house
which you should not read at age 14 is
bad
it's really negative um
so so uh but then i read the
hitchhiker's guide the galaxy was
like quite positive i think and um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is
that a lot of times the question is
harder than the answer and if you can
properly phrase the question
then the answer is the easy part and so
uh the if to agree that we can
um better uh understand the universe
then we
better know what questions to ask and
then whatever the question is that most
approx approximates what's the meaning
of life you know
that that's that's the question we could
ultimately get closer to
understanding um and so i thought well
to agree that we can expand the scope
and scale of consciousness
and knowledge um
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing and habit number five the
last one before a very special bonus
habit
is always be a student with bill gates
you went to harvard and you dropped out
have you ever thought how
your life could be better off if you had
gotten your harvard degree
well i i'm a weird dropout because i
take college courses all the time i love
learning company courses and and things
so i loved being a student
and there were smart people around and
you know they fed you
and they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart
uh so i i feel it was unfortunate
uh that i didn't get to stay there but i
don't think i missed
any knowledge because you know whatever
i needed to learn i would
i was still in a a learning mode now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
one of the things that companies do or
startups do
they come up with an idea they'll google
it and if they don't see it in the first
two pages
they think it's original you've got to
go back
right because over the past 15 years
there's so many different businesses
that have tried and failed
you have to go back and find those and
learn from those so you've got to
understand
all the implications and you have to
learn from history and so the best
advice i can give you on a video before
talking to you or emailing with you
is that you've got to find out the
history
of people who have tried your idea
because there's a 99.99999
chance that your idea has been tried
before that's not a good reason not to
start it because you might be able to
outperform them
but you better learn from the history of
your idea
um because you know what they say about
people who don't learn from history
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me and if you want seven more lessons
from billionaires check the video right
there next to me
i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe i'll see you there